hey everyone my name is gary vaynerchuk  series 2. i just want to say if  someone's [ __ ] gratitude okay i'm  just so [ __ ] happy to be the only  real authentic gary vee like check one  two hold on one second [ __ ] i'm gary v  series three who the [ __ ] are you dick  wait so bro like i'm not the only gary  vee  nope bro like i have a [ __ ] question  for you my man do you [ __ ] with  blueberries yup yup love it love it  lovely [ __ ] you bite your nails can i  get a hit of that yeah for sure until  real [ __ ] [ __ ] delicious do you wash  your hands do i wash my hands nope never  yeah me neither i think between the two  of us we're amazing it's almost like who  needs the original garyvee right  daddy is home who the [ __ ] are you i'm  the [ __ ] series one [ __ ] series one  [ __ ] i love that [ __ ] let's hear it for  these two  can someone get this man an nft  i love you guys love you guys  [Music]